[Music]
hello again and welcome back this is
Hoff here with Pop-A-Lock Northern
Colorado and the auto prop head G2 turbo
today we're working on a 2012 Hyundai
Veloster lost smart key we have our new
smart key here
not programmed key light comes on got
the hazards going I need to pull the pin
code in order to program
the new smart key
all right security authorization codes
it's a 46 smart card read with OBD
all right this guy has to be connected
to the internet which we are open and
close the door hazard lights are going
where's our pan
seven five six six nine eight
and back out
all right section type we're gonna try
smart key USA
it says without card slot I think
program smart keys
seven five six six
nine eight
all right new smart key to the button
press start button
all right program success no we're only
programming one
there we go
you need to back out
lock unlock
key in my lab
turns on
power starts
2012 Hyundai Veloster lost smart key
Auto Pro pad G2 turbo thanks for
watching
[Music]